Republicans love to be holier than now
and talk about taking care of kids and keeping kids safe in school
yet they're the first ones to complain in any conversation about gun control
any conversation that threatens Second Amendment
like we are consistently consistently seeing children's lives be destroyed
because you wanna be able to shoot a gun
they are the biggest bunch of hypocrites
I have ever had the misfortune of encountering
because you cannot say you care about kids when you are directly
directly contributing to their trauma and loss of life
we're the only country that has school shootings as a part of our culture
if that is not the sign of a corrupt society
I really do not know what is